after an illegal alien harassed u.s
senator kirsten cinema yesterday in a
women's bathroom at arizona state
university
you might think they would have
tightened up her security but no
another illegal alien also in no fear
whatsoever of facing punishment for the
crime that she is presently committing
harassed senator cinema on an airplane
i just want to know if um
you can commit as my senator as you if
you can commit
to passing
a reconciliation
that could provide a pathway to
citizenship
for
immigrants
you have been waiting for this for too
long
i need to know if you can commit
to passing about your reconciliation
that would include immigration and
citizenship for people to be protected
like me and many others
can you commit to that senator
let me just do a single question
i'm being
vulnerable right now to you my dad
passed away
but my dad passed away
my dad passed away last year and he
didn't get to reunite with my family i
don't want to serve you but at the same
time i just want to see if you i can get
a commitment from you
this is deeply offensive not just to
senator cinema
to the american people and to our system
of government this foreign woman is
making a mockery of our borders and our
laws and our democracy and whatever else
whatever other slogans we hear that the
left embraces they don't they don't seem
to
enact them lots of other things here too
law enforcement though the media
the entire liberal establishment they
won't do a thing about it
because in reality they're all on the
same side as the kooky foreigners i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from the gamer odin
who says i love that they filmed
themselves both admitting to being
undocumented meaning illegal aliens and
illegally filming in a bathroom
yes two crimes and they they acknowled
this was the video yesterday when these
kooks followed cinema into the bathroom
they do it because they don't have any
fear of being held to account they know
they can flout our laws they can fly out
even the laws that prevent you from
chasing women into the bathroom and no
one's going to stop them who's going to
stop biden's going to stop them i don't
think so
means you really ought to protect
yourself which is what i would strongly
recommend express vpn if you are not
using a vpn right now you need to start
right now just go expressvpn download it
you get it on your on your web browser
you get it on your phone you click a
button it's done it's really easy okay
to stop people from seeing the sites
that you visit
you need to do what i do and use express
vpn without expressvpn every site you
visit could be logged by the
administrator of that network and that's
still true even when you're in incognito
mode okay you close the blinds you look
out you say ah no one's gonna see what
i'm looking at
www.dailywire.com no they actually will
know your home internet provider can
also see and record your browsing data
and in the us they're legally allowed to
sell that data to advertisers
expressvpn it's an app that encrypts all
of your network data reroutes it through
a network of secure servers so that your
private online activity stays just
that private super duper easy to use
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
michael
use my like expressvpn.com michael get
three extra months for free exp or
essvpn.com michael to learn more
so
this clip is part of a series i can't
help but imagine
that there's some coordination here
these the illegal alien in the bathroom
and the one on the airplane saying the
same sorts of things you know my family
died and my family is outside of the
country because we're foreigners and
we're not americans
but i couldn't go visit them because
then it would be hard to sneak back into
this country illegally and so you need
to just give me citizenship after i
broke your laws so that i can go visit
my relatives in other countries and then
come back here whenever i want
and and this woman
refers to herself as daca
daca you know daca is that the dreamers
and and the the
entire idea of the dreamers is that
they're just little kids it's not their
fault they're just little kids and what
are you gonna do you're gonna deport a
six-year-old
that woman doesn't look like a
six-year-old to me
how how long do we have to keep calling
them dreamers like they're 10 years old
when they have grandchildren can we stop
calling them i think some of them do
have grandchildren actually but there's
they're the dreamers
they're the special dreamers and that's
why we've got to reward them for
breaking our laws
and we have to reward them for chasing
female senators into the bathroom we
have to reward them for making a
nuisance of themselves on airplanes and
we have to reward them for making a
mockery of our system of laws and our
borders and our country
because they're the special dreamers and
everyone else they're not allowed to
have dreams that's the idea
it is very very offensive and very very
wrong and very very unjust and not
particularly compassionate that these
people aren't being deported
okay now now we have by the way i don't
know if you weren't watching that clip
this this lunatic woman is filming down
kirsten cinemas blouse another invasion
of privacy so that's what we're going to
do because of the special dreamers and
the special compassion that they deserve
we're going to let lunatics break
multiple laws and film down senators
blouses that's a good idea right hey joe
biden what are you going to do about
this well joe biden was asked that
question by a reporter and he shrugged
it off he said ah happens to everyone
mr president mr president you're talking
about how you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two
uh have been pressured over the weekend
by activists joe manchin had people on
kayaks show up to his boat tl adam
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them
um so it's it's it's part of the process
it's a part of the process so what what
biden is trying to do here is he's
trying to say look public figures get
hate mail public figures sometimes get
accosted in public that's just the way
that it goes okay it's no big deal
he's right about that it's true if you
are in any way a public figure you will
at least on occasion be accosted by
letter by email or in person
usually though you're not accosted in a
bathroom you're not followed into a
bathroom and
i guess now usually it does involve
foreign nationals but it shouldn't this
is a very simple problem to fix deport
these criminals
deport these people who should not be
here just enforce the laws that have
been on our books for decades and
decades and decades just do that and
then the senator won't get harassed in
the bathroom if you joe biden just did
the very very bare minimum of your job
she would not be getting harassed by
these people in the bathroom and on
airplanes but joe biden's not doing it
is it just because he's incompetent no
he is incompetent but it's not just
because he's incompetent he's shrugging
this off because he's on the same side i
actually don't mean to scapegoat the
illegal aliens they shouldn't be here
and they should leave but
they're the illegal aliens are actually
a pawn being used by the democratic
party to try to achieve a permanent
electoral majority and to undermine the
most basic laws of the country and to
overturn the american culture and upend
it that that is what they're being used
for that's why these people are being
permitted in
and being told that they need to be put
on a pathway of citizenship
this routine that we're seeing here
is a good cop bad cop routine okay the
foreign nationals in the bathroom and on
the airplane they're the bad cop joe
biden he's the good top look look it
just happens to everybody
happens to everybody joe come on come on
jack listen up being serious here just
vote for the bill
happen come on you don't want this to
keep happening to you
sure would be a shame if people kept
coming into the bathroom
filming you down your blouse kirsten
cinema wouldn't be a shame
vote for the bill that's that's the
implication here
it's a good cop bad cop routine you're
seeing it
played out not just between biden and
these people in the bathroom but
with the media with big technology with
the universities
with the schools don't forget the first
incident in the bathroom took place at
asu this is a taxpayer-funded
public university why are foreign
nationals even permitted on campus
why
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
well because they're sort of amer
they're undocumented
americans they're not
they are undocumented foreigners they
are undocumented citizens of other
countries if i just traipsed into
guatemala and i went to guatemala you i
would probably be arrested
almost certainly i would be arrested
but
the
other way does not quite work the woman
who did this yesterday sophia
marianovich
just writes out i will i will speak
about the controversy regarding
following senator cinema into the
bathroom when i have the time none of
you have a right to tone police my
desperate demands for labor protections
after what i've endured blah blah blah
blah
none of you have the right to tone
police me she says because we're saying
you know hey
even people on the left by the way are
saying uh maybe you shouldn't it's not
good to follow the women in the bathroom
none of you have the right to tone
police
not only do we have the right to tone
police you we have the right to police
you you have the right to arrest you and
kick you out of the country because you
don't belong here and this isn't your
country and the american citizens i
think still have some right to decide
who gets to come in and use their
government services and interfere in
their elections as you admitted that you
did don't we have that right isn't that
the basic
the basic
building block of our democracy as the
left loves to describe it
i thought so maybe
not
we certainly do have
that right
but i don't know if you you know this
the immigrants have no problems there
are no problems with them whatsoever
illegal aliens they don't commit any
crime they don't take any government
benefits they don't even spread
covid this according to dr anthony fauci
dr fauci a new kaiser family foundation
poll asked americans this week what they
thought the major reasons for high
coronavirus spread are and the top
reason that republicans gave in this
poll was immigrants and tourists
bringing coveted 19 into the u.s
are immigrants a major reason why kova
19 is spreading in the u.s
no absolutely not dan i mean if you just
look at the data and look at the people
who've gotten infected look at the
people who are in the hospital look at
the people who've died this is not
driven by immigrants this is the problem
within our country the same way it's a
problem with other countries throughout
the world
just look at the data dana i can't look
at the data because the people that
we're talking about by definition don't
have any papers they don't have any
documents we're not processing them
they're illegal aliens so you're telling
me that the triple vaxxed suburban mom
in
in the middle of the country who wears
15 masks on her face she very likely
will spread cove it to everyone and
that's why she has to lock down and
can't go to christmas but the illegal
alien crossing the border through very
dangerous filthy circumstances who
doesn't have any evidence of a vaccine
doesn't wear a mask doesn't do any of
that that guy can't spread covet that
according to dr anthony fauci just look
at the data
you know
some people still don't know what time
it is in this car they're still using
these old outdated talking points they
don't know what time it is when you want
to know what time it is i would
recommend you go check out movement i
love
a nice timepiece okay i have worn
watches and been fascinated by watches
since i was eight years old
and i am so honored that one of the
first advertisers we ever had on this
show was movement in a tiny apartment in
southern california two college dropouts
teamed up to create a watch company with
fair prices unexpected colors and clean
original designs and movement grew into
one of the fastest growing watch brands
in the world shipping to over 160
countries around the globe now movement
has expanded into blue light glasses
that protect your eyes from screens i
never look at screens now without
filtering out that harmful blue light
it's really really taxing on your eyes
they've got minimalist jewelry they've
got more style essentials that will not
break the bank all designed out of their
california headquarters the movement
watches have the look and quality of a
watch you pay 400 500 for at the
department store but costs a fraction of
that price because they are controlling
it start to finish they will cut out the
middleman if you want to elevate your
look with style that doesn't break the
bank join the movement get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns at
mvmt.com knowles
mvmt.com knowles
dr fauci
was asked
about an
obvious contradiction within the liberal
establishment which is
you're telling us that we need to lock
down we shouldn't really go out if we do
go out if we go to schools if we go to
work we should wear a mask we should use
a lot of purell we should have a not
just a double vaccine but a triple
vaccine and you're not fully vaccinated
until you do that and you you might even
have to cancel christmas it's too early
to tell if we can go to christmas
meanwhile
we have historic record numbers of
completely undocumented foreigners
pouring across our southern border
no evidence that they've had a vaccine
no evidence that they wear masks no
evidence that they're not sick they just
pour across
and thought she was asked doesn't that
seem a little weird he says no don't
worry
excuse me
no do not worry the immigrants do not
spread kovid only you dirty filthy
americans
only you american citizens you spread it
so you need to give me all your rights
and your way of life but all those
foreigners they're they're cool they're
clean come on in guys
come on hey underlay underlay right
that's basically what valuchi is saying
this would seem to be as is often the
case with dr fauci a political
calculation not
a scientific calculation he's been doing
this since day one when he said don't
don't wear the masks the masks don't
work oh actually you should wear the
masks and i only told you not to wear
the masks because i always thought they
would work but i was afraid that you you
peasants would buy them all up and the
healthcare workers couldn't get any but
now you have to wear them right dr fauci
who changes his decisions based on
politics rather than on
science
well dr fatchi just flip-flopped again
and christmas you remember we played the
clip yesterday dr fauci said it's too
early to know whether or not you can
celebrate christmas with your family
this year so
he got a lot of pushback for this he
goes back on cnn and he says this is
outrageous i'm being misinterpreted i
never said
that you can't celebrate christmas
you know i also said something over the
weekend that was taken completely out of
context
i was asked what could we predict for
this winter for like december and
christmas i was going to ask you
yeah i mean i say you hold off on that i
said
we don't know because we've seen slopes
that went down and then came back up the
best way to assure
that we'll be in good shape as we get
into the winter would be to get more and
more people vaccinated that was
misinterpreted as my saying we can't
spend christmas with our families which
was absolutely not the case
i will be spending christmas with my
family i encourage people particularly
the vaccinated people who are protected
to have a good normal christmas
with your family but just the way all of
the other disinformation goes around you
say something talking about a landmark
of a time and it gets misinterpreted
that i'm saying you can't spend family
christmas time which is nonsense you can
so all that all that disinformation that
goes around seemingly every time anthony
fauci opens his mouth do you notice he
contradicted himself in that clip just
within that clip he said i was totally
misinterpreted
people people were saying that i said
that it's too early to to know if you
can have christmas and look i'm saying
of course it's too early we shouldn't be
talking about this we can't know and
that's why i'm definitely gonna have
christmas with my family so which is it
is it too early to know and you can't
make a decision yet or will you
definitely be having christmas with your
family oh i'm sure you will be having
christmas with your family but will you
let the rest of us peasants oh the rest
of us proles have christmas i don't know
what what is it doctor i'm being
misinterpreted you people it was
completely taken out of context all
right what's the context here's the clip
we played it yesterday it's still pretty
fresh in my mind what did dr fauci say
just days ago asked the question can we
have christmas this year
we can gather for christmas or it's just
too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time
are we allowed to have christmas there
are three possible answers here yes no
or maybe maybe meaning it's it's too
soon to tell what does dr fauci say it's
just too soon to tell which means maybe
we can have christmas maybe we can't
have christmas
maybe we're gonna
cancel christmas don't forget last year
dr fauci told everyone i got the clip
for that one too dr fauci told everyone
last year 2020 sorry you really should
not be celebrating christmas
my advice would be something that i
think is going to sadden people because
everyone wants
the family warmth and get-together that
is so characteristic
of the christmas season but my
recommendation would be to curtail
traveling as much as you possibly can
visiting people even though it's such an
important part of the christmas spirit
keep the gatherings the dinners and the
indoor gatherings to as few people as
possible preferably for people that are
an integral part of the household and
avoid the kind of congregate settings
that have been so characteristic we're
saying to the best of your possibility
don't do that i know that's tough but i
believe that's the only way we're going
to prevent an even greater surge than
we're already seeing it's it's a cancel
christmas message in effect or postpone
it yeah and in some respects it is
unfortunately
how much clearer does fauci need to say
it because the interviewer actually does
he says so you're saying we're going to
cancel christmas yeah i guess i am
so now dr fauci as always has held every
position
on the issue
certainly since last year yes cancel
christmas no don't cancel christmas
maybe you need to cancel christmas he's
held two of the three positions
just in the last statement that he gave
what changed what did the science change
between a couple of days ago and today
or between the end of dr fauci's answer
most recent answer and the beginning of
it did the science change no
the politics changed the people reacted
to him and he realized that he wasn't
going to be able to get away with this
one so he had to loosen up he insinuated
that we very likely very possibly might
have to cancel christmas and then when
people pushed back he said no i didn't
say that what are you talking about it's
the what's so frustrating here is not
his incompetence though obviously he's
to some degree incompetent at science at
politics he's pretty adept
it's it's not even his
power hunger it's not even his
narcissism his self-adulation it's the
gaslighting i didn't say that what are
you talking about i did i have got the
clip i just
saved this clip i'm sure they're going
to take it down from youtube at some
point save this clip you can see all of
the different positions the man
has held
i think people are getting a little sick
of fouchy i think we've got fouchy
fatigue i've had fouchy fatigue since
day one
did you hear that little line he put in
there he said look just it always gets
misinterpreted when you give people a
date
of when things are going to go back to
normal then it gets misinterpreted oh
you mean like 15 days to slow the spread
you jerk it what was that 590 days ago
oh it was a little i was a little off
okay 15 days 590 days
a thousand days i was a little off okay
come on give me a break give me a break
give me a break you jerk you freaking
jerk i try not
i try not to get emotional but this guy
makes my blood boil and
the worst part of it is
as a cultural commentator here at the
daily wire i i am
very soon going to have to sit through
a geography of dr fauci this coming out
from disney plus
the the dr fauci documentary of this
living
saint who who seems to glide across the
earth
with the lightest and most angelic touch
of any bureaucrat in the government
when i think about my dad growing up i
certainly think about that seriousness
but very few people get to see
he's funny weird and really playful
god help us
in 1981 hiv aids was evolving rapidly
and frighteningly there was anger at the
government's response when you got sick
you were gone fast
it's affecting you now yeah
why
post stress syndrome
when coveted hit he became this target
my dad said we're going to get through
this whole thing and he's held that
you don't do it because you want to make
money you don't do it for the glory you
do it because you care when you're
involved in a race to stop a horrible
disease
you always feel you're not doing things
quickly enough
it's not that dr fauci
has not been doing things quickly enough
it's that he's been doing the wrong
things that's the problem he does things
pretty quickly he takes power very
quickly he's been doing it since the 80s
but he just does the wrong things
they're trying to make him out to be the
hero of aids dr fauci completely botched
aids
i we we've we've got to put out maybe
we'll put out some
series or something on that we've got to
we've got to put out some information he
blew dr fauci is i'm not going to say
he's the villain of aids but he is
he is one of the people who really
really blew it and he blew it in a
similar way to the way that he blew
covid19
okay post-traumatic yeah you probably do
have post-traumatic stress syndrome
because you blew it buddy and and yet
because he he might not be the most
scientifically or medically adept but he
is extremely politically adept which is
how he's stuck around
so long
if you want to protect yourself your
data your identity i would strongly
recommend you check out lifelock have
you ever received a call text or email
from someone posing as an irs agent a
police officer or the power company
demanding payment by a gift card i've
had these sorts of things happen to my
relatives if you have you're probably
being targeted for a gift card scam
these fraudsters trick victims into
sending online gift cards or reading the
numbers from a gift card over the phone
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web if they detect
that your information has potentially
been compromised they will send you an
alert
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 percent off your first
year at lifelock.com
knowles k w l e s that is lifelock dot
com slash knowles for 25 off protect
yourself protect your identity protect
your data today
lifelock.com
slash knowles k-w-l-e-s for 25 off also
you got to check out ben's show today
about how joe biden doesn't give two
hecks
about norms standards and norms he
doesn't he doesn't give a darn if you
ask me
plus you got to check out morning wire
subscribe and listen to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a 5 star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
all the world is a stage and our
government whether you're talking about
the public health bureaucracy whether
you're talking about law enforcement is
a particular sort of proscenium
it's a particular kind of stage with a
whole big show
that that doesn't always relate to
reality right
the the way that
i mean we've seen it probably in the
last year and a half most closely with
the public health bureaucracy
but you're seeing it play out elsewhere
too
this charade of the government the idea
that the reality of government the
appearance of government are kind of
different even the way the government
works right we're told and school has
rock i'm a bill up on capitol hill three
branches of government separation of
powers checks and balances and that's
just kind of bunk that's not real right
actually the way the government works is
that the president passes an executive
order onto osha and then the
occupational safety and health
administration twists the arm of
companies with more than 100 employees
and that will work its way through the
courts but not before the mandate goes
through right i mean it's it's a much
more byzantine system than we like to
pretend that it is
and they very often don't believe the
things that they want the rest of us to
believe so there was a press briefing
yesterday at the department of justice
and there was a camera that was looking
just off stage right
okay so you're looking at the screen and
to the left of the screen you see some
doj flack and he doesn't have a mask on
because normal people don't wear their
masks in
basically any setting where they're not
compelled to so then the guy's about to
go on stage what does he do he puts the
mask on
so he's stan and then he immediately
takes the mask off because he got to the
podium so this is a guy who has not worn
a mask almost certainly all day long
he's standing in the wings of the stage
and he's just standing there dude he's
holding his mask and he's like okay well
time to go on time to go on stage so he
puts the mask on two seconds later takes
it off but he's got to give the
appearance that he's been wearing his
mask all day long and why does he have
to do that not because he thinks that
the masks matter obviously he doesn't
think the masks do anything at all he
doesn't wear them
but he wants you to do so he wants to
give you the impression
that he is behaving differently the
government is behaving differently and
you should behave differently than the
reality would suggest
and this is just to show you
a little hint of the deception
at the doj
the real story is this
merrick garland the attorney general who
we were all hoping would be moderate
probably compared to the other pixie is
relatively moderate it just shows you
how far the democratic party has moved
to the left merrick garland is
instructing the fbi
to
consider parents who oppose critical
race theory
to be domestic
terrorists
so you do you have kids out there you
listeners i something tells me if you're
listening to this show you probably
don't think all that favorably of
critical race theory you probably don't
support it being taught in schools will
you in the eyes of merrick garland's
department of justice
are a domestic terrorist
all right
the the order that comes out let's see
do i have a copy of the order yes i do
memorandum from the attorney general
in recent months there's been a
disturbing spike in harassment
intimidation threats of violence against
school administrators board members
teachers and staff who participate in
the vital work of running our nation's
public schools the vital work that we
shut down for a year over a cough while
spirited a cough that didn't propose any
particular threat to children while
spirited debate about policy matters is
protected under our constitution that
protection does not extend to threats of
violence or efforts to intimidate
individuals based on their views
threats against public servants are not
only illegal they run counter to our
nation's core values
yeah so now it's all about these three
it's really it's called this is the matt
walsh memo
right this is don't show up to the
school districts and tell them what you
want this is a threat that's domestic
terror and we got to stop it
something tells me
merrick garland would not have sent out
such a memo
over the blm riots
blm which was actually not just
threatening people but actually killing
people and stealing their property and
burning down their homes and businesses
and attacking federal courthouses you
probably wouldn't but but you
suburban mom who doesn't want your kid
being fed this racial and sexual poison
in the schools
that all white people are evil and
that america is an evil place and that
boys can be girls and that boys should
mutilate themselves if they feel like
girls so when they're four years old or
something if if you oppose that you're
you're the terrorist you're the threat
it's such a it's such a charade it's
such a farce
i'm i'm just shocked that the department
of justice had time to craft this memo
when uh when they're usually just so
busy trying to entrap radical right
wingers at
honeypot picnics do you remember that
you remember the justice for january 6th
rally and who showed up to the justice
for january 6th it was the press
and it was more press and it was
undercover fbi agents
who were sticking out they were glowing
in the dark as could be it was like a
sore thumb
that's what it is
we talked about this yesterday because
there was a ku klux klan hoax it turned
out to be a 30 year old black woman
woman was pretending to be a klansman
and threatening her neighbors
and and i pointed out to you that the
membership of the ku klux klan in the
united states is about 50 hoax artists
like the 30 year old black woman and 50
federal law enforcement officials
and like one guy and jimbo in the
mountains somewhere there's all he
didn't get the memo that the ku klux
klan hasn't been a thing for decades but
that's it it's all just a farce it's not
real the the show that you're seeing
before you
playing out at the level of the federal
government is not particularly real
all right what what you're really seeing
here
is the weaponization of the arms of the
government and also of a fictional
narrative to stomp out any kind of
dissent
if you oppose
flooding the country with illegal aliens
who harass senators in bathrooms if you
oppose
i don't know shipping manufacturing jobs
overseas if you oppose getting rid of
election integrity measures if you
oppose the separation of powers if you
oppose the slaughter of a million babies
a year why you're a domestic terrorist
and you need to be stomped at and if you
oppose critical race theory and radical
gender theory and teaching your little
boy that he should should mutilate his
genitalia to become a little girl
because that's totally
then you're a domestic terrorist
and you do not have the right to dissent
we support vigorous debate unless you
disagree with us then
then they try to stomp you out
speaking of radicalism specifically on
the sexual front
playboy
has a new cover
guess they have a new cover every single
issue
playboy
you know when i was younger i would read
it for the articles you'd always read it
for the articles but i i have not seen a
playboy and i don't know since i was a
teenager or something i don't know i
don't even know it was really still
around it seems like so dated now in the
era of the internet and the era of
pretty soon we're gonna have like
hologram porn stars walking around our
society so playboy seems a little
outdated they're trying to get i think a
little more
excitement and a little more publicity
and so what have they done they've put a
man
on the cover of their magazine
they've got this guy i think he's a
filipino guy he's like a social
influencer i don't i don't know his name
i'm happy to say
there's now a man dressed up as a woman
in a skimpy little bunny outfit on the
cover of playboy
a lot of people are looking at this and
saying
this is crazy oh my gosh it's the
inversion of playbook the whole point of
playboy is you have hot naked women and
then men pretend to read it for the
articles but they're just looking at the
women and now you've got dudes on there
that doesn't make any sense does it i
actually think the people who are
criticizing this decision are missing
the point i think it makes perfect sense
i think it is
intrinsic in the logic of playboy and
the playboy philosophy
that eventually you'd get some dude in a
skimpy outfit dressing up like a woman
on the cover of the magazine there's a
great episode of firing line william f
buckley jr's old show where it's him and
hugh hefner
back in the early days of playboy
debating the playboy philosophy
okay and it's really worth watching
because you see these two guys and you
you really see two different ways of
life you've got buckley who's kind of
herbane and laughing and
you know
educated and restrained and you've got
hugh hefner
who
looks nervous and he's jittery and he's
he just looks kind of creepy and he
sounds kind of creepy and he's obviously
not even close to his intelligent or
educated and they're debating the
playboy philosophy what's the playboy
philosophy
give yourself bodily pleasure
that's the philosophy give yourself
bodily pleasure so if
if
the
world
every consideration that we have to make
about how we behave in the world only
run skin deep if it only comes down to
the flesh
then why would you
not have a man who looks kind of like a
girl on the cover of your magazine
that's for girls if there's no
difference
if it's just meat right if it's all if
it's just flesh if it's just body then
if a guy looks kind of like a girl
why
why would you not have him on
there's no spiritual difference there's
no metaphysical difference it's just
physical
so one yeah he looks like a little bit
of a weird guy he doesn't look like a
total normal girl not like a busty buxom
playboy bunny but
he doesn't look all that masculine
either he looks kind of effeminate so
sure why not put him on
why not what's the difference
if you take a view of sex that is more
traditional christian jewish muslim
pagan for that matter i guess uh you
know
if you take a view of sex that is not
purely materialist
then you might say well it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if the guy
undergoes surgery and looks exactly like
a woman you still shouldn't put him on
the cover of playboy but if you're if
you're a materialist as the playboy
philosophy would have you be
makes perfect sense go enjoy your
go enjoy your dude on the cover of
playboy
materialists speaking of the playboy
lifestyle
outside of the realm of sex into the
halls of congress
congressman aoc
is calling
for a four-day work week
so
this is in response to a tweet from a
guy who coincidentally is actually a pal
of mine from college but he was just he
tweeted out he said we need a three-day
weekend one for errands one for social
activities one for staying in bed like
we've got some victorian wasting disease
so it's kind of just i think he was just
making a joke on twitter it's just a
sort of
funny tweet of you know look we get so
busy on the weekends there's not enough
time to do everything why do we have to
work so much hahaha
aoc retweets this and says four day work
week baby
rep mark takano has got a bill for that
so she's taking this joke
and she's
taking it further and saying uh no we
actually need to make this a law you you
should only work four days a week
now
this would seem a bad idea to me i know
this is an unpopular opinion but i don't
think we should have a four day work
week i think people are meant to work
and i think the theory is
that when you have a lot of time off
when you have a lot of leisure time then
you're going to pursue all of these
interests that you have you know this
was the argument for obamacare when you
don't need to work anymore
to have say health insurance or some
kind of basic
ability to live
you're going to become a poet
you're going to become a painter
you're oh you're going to write the next
great american novel aren't you
and
actually almost certainly you will not
that's not what happens actually because
it turns out it's hard to paint and it's
hard to write poetry it's hard to write
a novel and you need to work at it
relentlessly and it's not just a sort of
thing you do oh it's a saturday
afternoon i think i'm going to go write
a novel yes that's what i'm no that's
just not how it works
we are made
to work okay now that does not mean that
you need to slave away all your life at
the widget factory or you know at the
retail shop or whatever there are other
ways to
do things
but
you you know
some of your free time should then be
spent with your family
doing things not just like loafing
around on the couch but actually doing
things with your family some of that
time should be spent fixing up the house
some of that time should be spent
cultivating interests and hobbies and
activities not writing the next great
american novel maybe but reading a
little bit being productive and then
what's entirely left out of this
discussion it was reading all the
comments uh first my friend's joke then
aoc's
broader you know legislative take on
this and then all the people saying
here's what we need to do on the
weekends what's left out of this is
honoring god keeping holy the sabbath
day having one day of the week to think
about eternal things
which
was
taken for granted in virtually every
society
for virtually all of the entire history
of the world
until very recently where we've totally
forgotten about that and and the
argument for getting rid of the sabbath
day was
oh this is gonna this is way better i'll
get to relax more i'll get to be more at
peace i'll get to be more at leisure and
in fact what has happened is the
opposite
right we we loaf around when when you've
got a couple days off you just loaf
around and you don't really
do any you don't feel good you don't
feel energized you've you are meant to
be doing things idle hands are the
devil's playground thought slothful
people are the brothers
of destroyers so says proverbs
and i'm not surprised that aoc would
would
promote idleness and sloth and laziness
makes perfect sense to me speaking of
inactivity though speaking of people who
are going to have a lot of very long
weekends coming up
there is
earth-shattering news in washington that
is not getting a ton of play namely
the head
of the national institutes of elf is
stepping down this is not dr fauci
he's the head of
niaid this is one of the institutes at
the nih
but the head of the nih dr francis
collins longest serving head of the nih
he's stepping down
according to reports from politico
why is this at the time when the nih is
most under scrutiny for their
involvement in the coronavirus epidemic
and then the lockdowns as a result of it
why is the head of nih stepping down now
politico reporting that dr francis
collins at the head of the nih longest
serving director ever will step down
after 12 years it's not clear exactly
why it could be personal reasons could
be that he's just been there long enough
he wants to step down he's tired could
be health reasons we don't know i'm not
not going to speculate could be that
it's just time you know it's just time
it's been been long enough
however
it might be political
because there is a scandal here okay
and it's been covered up by the press
and you only hear it occasionally if
rand paul is grilling dr fauci or
somebody before
before the senate
but
the nih was involved
in funding gain of function research
the same sort of research that
almost certainly caused the outbreak of
the coronavirus
the nih was involved in funding the
wuhan institute of virology
where the virus almost certainly escaped
from
the nih lied about their involvement in
gain of function research and the wuhan
institute of virology and
dr fauci
perjured himself
certainly in the mind of rand paul
perjured himself on this very question
but you can't fire dr fauci because dr
fauci is the indispensable man he just
said the other day to hugh hewitt there
is no circumstance in which i will
resign there is none absolutely none
joe biden was asked would you fire
anthony fauci at all for any reason no
he would not and so there is a world in
which francis collins head of nih is
taking the fall here i don't care i
don't care about francis collins i
barely even care about dr fauci
the less i think about dr fauci the
better my blood pressure is
but
do not lose sight of the scandal the
scandal here is very important it
reminds us that the geniuses who
presume to run our lives better than we
can run them ourselves are actually
idiots
a lot of the time they don't run our
lives all that well
and they're trying to cover this thing
up and they think oh maybe you know if
we switch up some people take some heat
off this issue maybe it'll go away do
not let it go away this is the issue
keep it up speaking of scandal
and the job search
matthew dowd is the former chief
strategist on the bush cheney 04
campaign he was a republican but he's
like a bushy republican so he's not
particularly conservative now he's a
democrat like so many of them are like
so many former bush officials and bush
supporters he is a democrat and he's
running for lieutenant governor of texas
as a democrat
and
he very recently just deleted
all of his tweets he just deleted all
hundreds of thousands of tweets he just
deleted all of them and cnn to its
credit brought him on the show
on cnn new day and said hey
what are you hiding
matthew uh you're well aware you're
being attacked by republicans and fox
for deleting thousands of tweets
how many tweets did you delete
i don't know i think what i did was and
this was long before this is funny about
fox who looks for anything to sort of
come up with some conspiracy theory as
they do
uh earlier in the summer i thought i
have 270 260 000 tweets that have just
been accumulated i just decided to go
through and delete all of my old tweets
whatever it happened to be so there's
there's no conspiracy thing here it's
just cleaning up my files long before i
even thought about running uh in this
race but again it's a typical fox thing
that
to turn to some conspiracy thinking it
has more meaning than it actually does
why did you do it then
i
i just said brianna i did it because i
just wanted to clean up all of my files
and get rid of all of the stuff that
accumulated over time there's no reason
as you i understand that but this isn't
like emptying your email inbox to be
clear
i love her good job honor this you're
really asking the right questions here
lady and you'll notice this clip goes on
for at least another minute if not
another two minutes and he just keeps
repeating the same thing i was it's just
funny i was fox news conspiracy theory
ha cleaning up my inbox conspiracy fox
inbox cleaning up and she points out no
deleting your tweets
it's not like cleaning out your email
inbox you have to clean out your email
inbox every so often because you only
get a certain amount of storage and so
then it fills up and then you can't get
new emails so you go in and you delete
your emails and then you can receive
more emails
with twitter
you can tweet as much as you want it's
fine there's it's you're not storing
files on your computer or in your
personal twitter account
moreover when you delete your emails on
your email client
it's very easy you click a button you
click you click at most what three
buttons and then you can delete all your
emails and it's easy and it just happens
with twitter you've got to go through
all those tweets and it's actually time
intensive certainly what he did was hire
a campaign person to go through and
scrub all of his old tweets
and
and so he he thought about this he
planted that there is a reason why
and we all know the reason why because
he said things that are going to get him
in trouble and i have some sympathy he's
such a little weasel that i i don't have
a ton of sympathy because he should just
come out and say oh because we live in a
cancel culture and anything i said 15
years ago is going to be used to shoot
down my campaign so i don't want to give
my opponents ammunition
whether you agree with that or not
whether you agree with that tactic or
not at least it would be honest that's
what he was doing
and and i get it we now
previously if you ran for
lieutenant governor 20 years ago people
would comb through newspapers and find
things that you had said now they can
just look through 200 000 tweets and
inevitably something you tweet will be
off color or taken out of context or you
won't even agree with it anymore so yeah
you want to delete it you don't want to
give them
you don't want to give your opponents
the ammunition
although now that he's called attention
to it people are probably going to go
back because there are records of these
things online but so the weaseliness i
don't like but there is something here
which is even bigger beyond this
schlub and beyond cnn
you are damned if you do and you are
damned if you don't in this culture one
because of the growth of surveillance
technology there is a record of
everything we've ever done or said or
practically even thought in some cases
literally things that we've thought
because these algorithms actually can
predict your behavior and impel certain
behavior
but
but beyond that
you
live in a culture now where there's no
grace
there's no forgiveness so you can
in the olden days you could you could
say oh yeah i tweeted something 10 years
ago but i don't agree with it anymore
yeah i was i was a little hot at the
time that's okay you know sorry move on
it's not a big deal okay i forgive you
all right we're good but we don't live
in that culture we live in
this particular cancel culture where
there is no grace because there's not a
lot of shared trust because there's not
a shared vision of america because we
don't even have borders we don't even
have a common language anymore and so in
that kind of a culture where there's
very very little national cohesion
you are going to have to live in a world
in which you are
deceiving
well not where you have to but where
this will typify the culture where
you're deceiving where you are
gaslighting or you're pulling a fouchy
where you're deleting things where
you're hiding things where you're
covering up where you are telling people
don't believe your own lying eyes and
your lying ears how long can a culture
persist in that unstable way and still
remain a nation i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles shall see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
makes excuses for protesters following a
democratic senator into a bathroom while
the media prepare a full frontal assault
on facebook in order to suppress
conservative information that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen